jean françois bach bonjour
merci merci d'avoir accepté notre
invitation ce matin sur rtl france on le
disait à l'instant l'om est-ce
déconseille donc cette fameuse troisième
dose pour ne pas creuser le fossé entre
les pays pauvres et les pays riches
finalement c'est bien cela
oui oui mais je pense qu'il faut
doubler bien faire la différence entre
le problème immunologiques et médical
d'une part et le problème humanitaire
d'autre part parce que du point de vue
médical la troisième dose se justifie la
haute autorité de santé gouvernementaux
l'ont dit et c'est vrai alors c'est pas
vrai forcément pour tout le monde
maintenant pour tous les sujets âgés il
y à des personnes qui en ont plus besoin
que d'autres les personnes qui sont
fragiles
sont d'ordre très âgé et éventuellement
plus de 75 80 à la rando france en
france on a parlé de 65 ans d'autres
pays ont parlé de 40 ans d'autres pays
de cas
65,6 raisonnable le problème c'est que
il faut vraiment se focaliser sur ce
qu'ils ont besoin notamment donc le
sujet très âgés et les sujets qui ont
en cause de comorbidité qui ont une
cause d'immuno suppression autrement dit
les sujets qui sont les plus à même de
père
protection
finalement ces protections elle diminue
avec le temps
finalement cette troisième dose dès
l'âge de 30 ans que vous nous dites
c'est que c'est pas forcément nécessaire
aujourd'hui ce qui se fait en israël par
exemple des là je me transforme
le voyez le problème c'est que il est
normal que limites
apportées par un vaccin baisse avec le
temps au départ ou savait pas combien de
temps ça au bout de combien de temps ça
baisserait maintenant on sait que c'est
probablement ça recommence
ils étaient six moines mais pas de façon
dramatique pour les sujets ordinaires
pour les sujets en bonne santé c'est
très lent donc il n'y a pas
péril en la demeure en revanche pour les
sujets qui sont fragiles
je les ai cité tout à l'heure cela c'est
peut être un vrai problème donc il est
bon de se poser la question alors côté
qu'est ce qu'on sait très
côté persiste en deux ans les anticorps
par exemple mais le fait est là il ça ne
concerne pas tout le monde alors à
partir de ça sur un plan humanitaire le
dirai même même épidémiologie il faut
si une troisième dose il faut vraiment
que ce soit utile parce que il ya quand
même deux problèmes persistants en
français le problème
est qu'ils permettent pas encore
vaccinés et il y en a encore quand même
un nombre relativement important cela
débat dans lequel je vais pas rentrer et
puis dans le monde alors là c'est un
problème énorme
maintenant ici il faut vraiment mettre
en balance le nombre de doses qui serait
utilisé pour la troisième dose dans un
pays comme le nôtre et le nombre de
doses qu'il faut pouvoir donner aux pays
en développement les pays émergents qui
rend complètement si ces quelques
millions de doses en france dans le
qui vive c'est pas une quantité
considérable par rapport aux centaines
de millions de doses qui sont
nécessaires pour ces pays c'est donc il
est question de mesure et
personnellement je pense que si on se
focalise sur les sujets que vont
vraiment deux ans en france et il faut
le mettre en route et puis bien sûr pas
à il a tout faire pour aider les pays du
tiers-monde merci beaucoup jean françois
bach on a eu un petit souci de liaison
mais on a bien entendu un votre
éclairage merci à vous d'avoir été avec
nous sur rt france je le rappelle nous
est biologiste immunologiste secrétaire
perpétuelle honoraire de l'académie des
sciences